how durable is Captain America in the  comics warning this answer is going to  include images from the comics that  contain depictions of blood  and during one of Camp's Adventures he  was transported to another Universe  where Arnhem Zola was taking over and  creating horrible monsters in this  adventure Zola also implemented some  robotics into cap resulting into this  obviously Steve doesn't want soul in his  chest so what does he do after stabbing  the Zola device out of his chest Steve  assaults a heavily fortified building in  order to defeat Zola and manages to  survive most of us would struggle to  survive the stabbing in the first place  he's pretty durable  foreign  [Music]